[Music]
you can get much further with a kind
word in a gun
than with a kind word alone
a bullet changes a lot in your head
even if it hits in the ass
can you forgive an enemy
god will forgive
our task is to arrange their meeting
[Music]
nothing personal it's just business
as a child i prayed to god for a bicycle
then i realized that god works
differently
i stole my bike
and prayed for forgiveness
some people play safe
not to lose
you will definitely lose if you play
safe
i will give three dozen of my thugs for
one person who can solve questions by
talking
hell must be a pretty swell spot
because the guys that invented religion
have sure been trying hard to keep
everybody else out
if your friends ask you to negotiate
with your enemy
then the traitors have already agreed
behind your back
be correct with everyone
sociable with many
close to the elect
friend to the few
be careful who you call your friends
i'd rather have four quarters than 100
pennies
sometimes it's better to tolerate fools
you can learn something worthwhile
but never argue with them
the world belongs to the patient
do not shake the green apple tree
when the apple is ripe
it will fall down by itself
i'm a businessman
i've made my money supplying a popular
demand
if i break the law
my customers are as guilty as i am
listen to the advice that gives you an
advantage
but do not give such advice to anyone
[Music]
don't test the depth of the river
with both feet
work out the problems as they come up
capitalism is the legitimate racket of
the ruling class
[Music]
everything you do comes back to you
the country wanted booze and i organized
it
why should i be called a public
enemy all the dead were hanged on me
with the exception of the victims of
world war ii
if you must lie
be brief
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments
don't miss out on a chance to see the
next video
subscribe
[Music]
you